Until now we haven't really done anything about over plotting.
That's when multiple points take on the same value. This is
often due to rounding. So let's look at this by
running some code. We're going to run the table command on both
carat, and price. Then we're going to sort that so that
the highest values appear first. We're just going to look at the
top six which is the default for the head function.
Of course, what's happening here is that the first line is
the price or the carat, and the second line
is the count for each one of these values. We
can see that these are really high numbers which is
going to result in a substantial amount of overplotting. When you
have this much data, you're going to have serious overplotting, even
when you're plotting the variables against each other, and this
can really obscure some of the density and the sparsity
of our data. Really key points. Okay, so as we
discussed in lesson four, you can deal with this by
making your points smaller by jittering your points and by
adding transparency. In gg plot, this is done with the
alpha parameter. In the next coding exercise, you'll do just that.